this is what we're required to prove
i've got part a there
so let's just assume that we've done
that okay i've got part b
okay that f is increasing
in this domain uh let's see
and now you've got this weirdo
inequality all right
now the first clue with the inequality
is that they give you a very specific
restriction
namely this
okay so this is your by the way this is
your first call you remember to talk
about squeeze law right
this is your first crew that this is not
squeezed law squeeze law is about limits
this is about a certain interval of
theta
right nothing to do with squeeze law
okay now
you've got this three part inequality
and then you have to prove a three-part
inequality
right so you need to be okay these have
a connection to each other
now i think three or four of you saw it
three or four of you saw it
and you concluded this as f is
increasing
in in this domain
okay um therefore i can say
this statement
oops
can you see what that means right um for
this new
much more restricted domain which is
within what you proved in part
b okay what's going on here
this is just saying look i'm going up
right or something like that
okay i just proved that from naught
to pi on two you're going up the whole
time
right so if you take a value at pi on
three that's like somewhere like there
you take one of those values right and
then you take one of these values
then any of those should be somewhere in
between that's all it means
that's all it means okay now if you saw
this
you could evaluate and that was not hard
right um
because don't forget f is not this
it's just the denominator right so you
would do this
and this right here this awful looking
long mess which is not that bad it's
just long
that was your first mark okay so you had
to recognize that this comes from part b
and so you can evaluate it and that's
your basis for proving this inequality
this particular for these particular
values that they give you okay
so you do a whole bunch of simplifying
all these signs and causes right
you end up with this
that's where you end up now
excuse me at this point you simplified
as far as you get
right any time there's sort of like
stages throughout the question right
and you're like look i've reached the
end of a stage i've simplified as far as
i can from from this mess
right at that point you're like okay now
where do i go
and the thing is they've given you a
road map that told you where you need to
head right
now this is not what you want to prove
this
and this are upside down and they're in
the wrong spots
so you're like hmm well what does that
mean okay
well if i want some reciprocals right i
should take reciprocals of everything
right and that's that would work if i
take a reciprocal of this i would get
this value
which is what i want somewhere right if
i take a reciprocal of this i get this
and if i take a reciprocal of this i get
this so all the numbers are right now
that's
really good you are so close ah
but what happens here can you see what's
going on
right if you take reciprocals
reciprocals are a weird thing
i can say three is less than four which
is less than five
but if you take reciprocals it's no
longer true
because a third is not less than a
quarter and a quarter is not less than a
fifth
when you take reciprocals a bigger
denominator means a smaller number
so everything's been turned around like
so
does that make sense so therefore on
this slide even though it's weird
you have to write your inequalities
backwards okay
but that's weird and it's not what you
were trying to prove so you put it
around the right way
and there's the result
okay now you can see they give you
tremendous clues to get you here
right they've told you all about it
being an increasing function
in part one you got this result which is
going to lead you into part c
okay oh sorry i should take part two so
do you see how i got there does that
make sense
um where were the two marks
excuse me um this is the first mark
evaluating
f at the relevant points um the second
mark i think was
here just before you took the
reciprocals right
is that right yes that's right because
once you do that you're basically home
and that's a foregone conclusion you get
nothing for that okay